all right so we can say a lot of
different things about uh steve bannon a
former breitbart propagandist a former
trump advisor we can say he's an immoral
person we can say he's a disgusting
individual we can say his politics are
all wrong and all of those things would
be true but steve bannon is not a stupid
guy when it just comes to basic
fundamental
uh
statements about how elections work for
example and that's why i'm not fully
getting
why steve bannon is continuing to say
that any day now donald trump is going
to be back in the white house and in
fact on his recent program um the war
room on real america's voice steve
bannon said trump's going to be back in
2022 or maybe even before now of course
donald trump is not going to be back as
president in 2022 or maybe even before
and i know that steve bannon knows that
so why is he saying it let's consider
that as we watch this clip take a look
at this the quiet part out loud today
the anxiety the hangry the pearl
clutching is the democratic party's fear
of the return of trump
that's what all these committees are
that's what they're trying to do that's
what this all the justice department is
this the senate that dick durbin's got
the long face
the return of trump and it ain't going
to be in 2024
it's going to be in 2022 or maybe before
as we start the decertification process
out in arizona let the americans there
is no such process
okay
now
i know uh steve bannon doesn't believe
that he just there's no way he he's he's
we can make a lot of criticisms of him
but he doesn't believe that
so is this the same as when steve
scalise won't answer when chris wallace
asks him again and again and again was
the election stolen from trump and steve
scalise answers every question other
than the one that's actually being asked
is it steve bannon's signaling i don't
know because steve bannon doesn't need
trump support to be re-elected for
example steve bannon is not in the same
position so why is steve bannon saying
this
now as far as the facts
remember that there's no mechanism that
makes this possible there's no you know
the line of succession is joe biden
kamala harris nancy pelosi
no one is doubting
i mean maybe they are but it's not part
of the story that nancy pelosi's
election in 2020 was also fraudulent
nancy pelosi is
uh duly elected
so if by some unknown means
that we don't even know
you get the presidential election thrown
out nancy pelosi becomes president it's
not donald trump the supreme court will
not be reinstating donald trump no one
will be reinstating donald trump i know
steve bannon knows this horrible person
but he's not this stupid so why is he
saying it maybe he wants clicks and this
gets him clicks i don't know
maybe it's a signal to people to prepare
for another violent coup attempt
neither is a great scenario i think the
coup is worse
from those two options
simply trying to monetize a dumb
audience is one thing but trying to
weaponize that audience into attempting
another riot i think is far worse
quite frankly it's not like there have
really been major consequences at least
yet for the rioters so why wouldn't you
go for another coup attempt if steve
bannon tells you that maybe it'll work
um also on decertifying arizona
whenever
you run out of ideas or your ideas are
totally rejected by reality
what they do is they come up with a new
word that people don't yet know much
about so they think maybe that could
happen the new word is decertification
of arizona will never happen it it's not
a thing and remember that even if it did
even if decertifying the arizona results
of the 2020 election in what is almost
2022 now even if they came up with a way
to do it
flipping arizona from trump to biden
doesn't change who won in 2020 anyway uh
arizona's 11 electoral votes joe biden
at 306 you need 270 to win uh without
arizona biden still has 295 so it's a
layer of nonsense upon layer of nonsense
and people fall for it and whether the
point is money
or it's to prepare people to get violent
again the next time that this doesn't
happen
or it's because steve bannon believes he
has to do this because it'll help him in
some way curry favor with donald trump
which maybe he still needs for some
reason i don't know
whatever the reason people
fall for this stuff
and it's extraordinarily dangerous and
it doesn't seem like it's going to stop
anytime soon
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night helps you
sleep i can't sleep in a hot room that's
why i love our sponsor chilly sleep
which makes customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions to sleep
better their flagship products are the
uhler sleep system and the cube sleep
system which is what i have both are
hydro powered temperature controlled
luxury mattress pads you can make them
as cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit if you
wanted you could go as hot as 115
degrees
i like the cooler option i keep mine at
60 degrees and it gives me a great cool
night of sleep no feeling hot no more
sweating i'm falling asleep faster and
it pairs perfectly with chili sleeps
weighted chili blanket which keeps you
cold on top too
they'll give you twenty percent off
everything when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video